John asks you give with zero expectation
of return so you're never disappointed
that's really tough how do you do it
John I do it because that was the talent
that I was gifted with it is it is the
essential backbone of my success I mean
I've said it to about other things so
it's always a mix right like it's hard
to say this but like boy boy am i
thankful that boy am i thankful that I
have it I you know I look forward in
others it is a huge competitive
advantage it's it's like being born
beautiful right it's a competitive
advantage luckily for me I got both for
me it is really really really really
really something that I I'm so thankful
for how do I do it the same way
everybody does everything it was just
there I didn't cultivate my lack of
expectation there's no like lack of
expectation exercises that you know that
you can get into but boy is it then a
look the truth is people like people
right and people do business with people
and people sense people through a camera
through an audio podcast they sense
people I have enormous selfishness on
the things that I want to achieve but
the fact that I have this lack of
expectation and I'm willing to give and
give chances and give opportunities and
just flat-out give without ever thinking
what am I going to get in return
knowing that 8 out of 10 times I will
get something out of turn and it's pure
it's just the purest version of it I won
and so like you know I have no clue how
to instill that but I can do this why I
answered this question I can tell you
that it's if it's in you triple down on
it don't suppress it
don't let the cynics outside of you tell
you know you're being too nice you're
not getting anything in return it is
enormous human leverage and I highly
highly highly recommend it oh crap wait
subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe